bonsoir nous sommes lundi 7 septembre
merci de ne retrouver pour votre journal
d'information tout de suite les titres
de votre actualité locale ce week-end
mobilisation d'une partie de la
population contre la fermeture prochaine
du centre de protection maternelle et
infantile de la verrière
le conseil départemental gestionnaire
bpm il souhaite réduire le nombre de
celles ci de 60 à 20 afin de réaliser
des économies en mutualisant les moyens
en culture nous vous présenterons une
partie de la programmation de la scène
national de saint quentin en yvelines
une programmation riche et diversifiée
lionel masse est à nouveau directeur
entend ouvrir le théâtre au plus grand
nombre
après le primaire après le secondaire
c'est au tour des grandes écoles et des
universités d'accueillir leurs élèves à
saint quentin en yvelines plusieurs
nouveautés
tout d'abord à l'estaca école
d'ingénieurs qui s'implante à montigny
le bretonneux
le chantier du campus est terminée et
puis lui vécu qui prépare son avenir
avec l'université de paris saclay
plusieurs de ces formations proposées
sous la bannière de cette nouvelle
entité dès ce mois de septembre
et pour en parler avec nous en plateau
deux invités jean luc vaissière
président de l'ue véhicules et pascal
riblon directrice de l'estaca à saint
quentin en yvelines
bonsoir à vos besoins et merci d'être
venus sur un autre par plateau pour
parler des enjeux de la rentrée pour
votre établissement pour vos
établissements respectifs
et puisque vous êtes voilà tous deux
réunis j'ai omis de vous poser une
question est il possible d'imaginer une
collaboration entre voilà aux deux
établissements bien moi je dirais que la
collaboration elle existe depuis depuis
un certain temps ça fait de nombreuses
années que l'estac a et
élu vs qu à travailler ensemble sur
différents projets et preuve en est elle
le fait que l'estac a faisait partie des
membres fondateurs d'une fondation
partenariale dédié aux véhicules
décarbonés communicants qui aujourd'hui
est devenu vd comme vous avez dû
sûrement parler assez souvent et un
projet qu'on avait développé ensemble
il reste à faire plus et mieux et c'est
mieux mais peut-être quelque chose
d'envisageable dans le futur ah oui
monsieur en plus il faut bien
reconnaître qu'à proximité géographique
est aussi à le développement de
collaborations même à l'heure du
numérique l'internet
eh bien nous y reviendrons donc quelques
instants mais tout de suite l'actualité
de ce lundi dans les yvelines c'est là
sculptures d'anish kapoor au château de
versailles encore vandalisé des
graffitis à caractère antisémite ont été
réalisés dans la nuit de samedi à
dimanche sur dirty corner l'oeuvre
polémique
surnommé aussi le vagin de la reine
l'artiste a fait savoir qu'ils
comptaient laisser son oeuvre en l'état
déclarant que ces mots instamment
faisait désormais partie de son oeuvre
la direction du château de versailles
condamne cet acte inacceptable bien
évidemment elle a renforcé la
surveillance du site
nous avons demandé aux visiteurs
présents ce qu'il pensait de ses textes
de vandalisme au château de versailles
regardez c'est lamentable
je pense que c'est des gens qui ont bien
compris qu'ils cherchent se faire
remarquer mais non seulement ça me
choque mais ça me fait peur une telle
violence une telle intolérance
on aime ou on n'aime pas mais on n'est
pas obligé de regarder on détruit des
monuments et puis même les oeuvres même
temps contemporaine si elles sont moches
mais enfin bon c'est quand même pas
faire à mon avis ne pouvait pas de tout
seul pour écrire aussi pour y faire
autant de textes devaient être
certainement plusieurs je suppose c'est
vraiment ridicule et complètement
dépassée de nos jours des réactions
pareil et le fait que l'artiste souhaite
laisser
l'état mais la raison comme ça il fait
voir la bêtise des gens
autre sujet je vous le disais en titre
une trentaine de personnes mobilisés
contre la fermeture probable du centre
de protection maternelle et infantile de
la verrière après une pétition qui a
déjà compilé plus de 1000 signatures
le bras de fer se poursuit avec le
conseil départemental en charge de la
gestion des établissements regardez ce
reportage signé wilfried richier et
william l environ 300 familles
fréquenterait ce centre de protection
maternelle et infantile située à la
verrière ce samedi matin une trentaine
de personnes entendait s'opposer à sa
fermeture envisagée par le conseil
départemental déplacer cette pmi vers
mort pas une idée évoquée par les élus
départementaux et qui passe donc mal
auprès d'une partie de la population et
des élus de la majorité
et ces derniers entendent d'ailleurs
plutôt obtenir la création d'une maison
de la santé interdisciplinaire on a sur
le territoire un peu un besoin aussi de
médecins de spécialistes qu'on n'a pas
qu'on n'a pas aujourd'hui
donc l'idée ça serait de construire un
équipement là où on se trouve d'ailleurs
et de la colle et à un service public
tel que la pmi
la pmi qui reste ouverte en ce début du
mois de septembre à la verrière mais le
conseil départemental entend bien
redéfinir l'intégralité de la carte des
centres car bédié son président l'a
répété en juin dernier il faut
moderniser et améliorer l'accueil des
familles mais aussi faire des économies
et donc regrouper les établissements
existants
je regrette cette décision parce que
elle montre une fois de plus quand il
s'agit
faire des économies on les fait au
détriment des populations les plus
fragiles
pinault est rappelons que les pmi assure
notamment une prévention médicale
psychologique et sociale en faveur des
futurs parents et des enfants
un service gratuit et dans le plan
envisagé par le département il ne
devrait rester que trois centres pmi sur
huit dans l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines
le centre de guyancourt situé au pont du
rotois du routoirs pardon devrait lui
aussi fermé ses portes malheureusement
la mairie a lancé une pétition
elle rappelle qu'en 2013 1078
consultations d'enfants y ont été
réalisés elle demande aux élus
départementaux de renoncer à cette
fermeture
je propose maintenant de passer à
l'entretien de cette édition
et avant de vous écouter jean luc
baissière et pascal ribot sur les enjeux
de cette rentrée pour vous et pour vos
établissements respectifs
je vous propose un aperçu de la rentrée
pour les étudiants l'unef
l'université de versailles saint quentin
fait sa rentrée cette semaine
en ce lundi associations et syndicats se
sont mobilisées dans le hall du campus
afin d'aider les nouveaux étudiants
un reportage signé fanny bourdillon
l'université de versailles saint quentin
fait sa rentrée cette semaine
en ce lundi associations et syndicats se
sont mobilisées dans le hall du campus
afin d'aider les nouveaux étudiants
on aide les étudiants étrangers ou ceux
en erasmus dans leurs démarches
administratives que ce soit pour trouver
un logement pour essayer d'avoir des
aides pour la caf ou même juste pour les
inscriptions administratives et
pédagogiques
ces démarches qui ne sont pas toujours
facile à gérer surtout quand on arrive
dans la région franchement pour les
démarches paperasse oui c'est toujours
stressant surtout quand on est pas on
sait pas où on fait l'inscription
administrative après pédagogique
il faut demander à l'hôtel personnes
franchement oui surtout la première
semaine
cette année l'université a préparé des
welcome pack une sacoche qui contiendra
tous les supports utile pour s'intégrer
une rentrée qui est attendu pour
certains et stressante pour d'autres ce
sont en plein stress parce que
l'université ne sait jamais comment ça
comment la neva signant notamment avec
les dernières années qu'on a vécu au
niveau de l'économie de l'économie des
économies de l'université tout ça après
cette année le président l'université
nous a dit que ça allait mieux qu'on
était plus sous tutelle donc on verra
moi personnellement ça me dérange pas
leur entrée au contraire après quatre ou
cinq mois de grandes vacances c'est
sympa de recommencer
la plupart des formations de l'ue vs qu
reprennent cette semaine et vous pouvez
dès à présent noté que la semaine du 22
au 29 septembre accueillera l'événement
valence l'assaut l'occasion de
rencontrer toutes les associations
étudiantes des campus et nous l'avons vu
beaucoup d'étudiants ont fait leur
rentrée ce lundi
selon l'unef les demandes d'inscription
à l'université généralement ont augmenté
de 6,5 pour cent en 2015 est ce que
c'est le cas ici à saint quentin en
yvelines
trop tôt pour le dire ce qu'on constate
c'est que vous derniers chiffres la
semaine dernière on était à 10 % au-delà
de il ya un an même époque
je pense qu'il faut prendre un peu de
recul pour voir les choses se faire plus
ou moins rapidement donc au moins déjà
sa baisse pas il est trop tôt pour
savoir effectivement si on est sur une
logique dynamique d'accroissement
effectifs ce qui évidemment est pour
effectivement posé des problèmes mais
voilà
ce serait positif dans le côté quand
même et le point important donc pour une
université c'est justement la
mutualisation avec l'université de paris
saclay et ça avance bien il ya 70% des
masters qui sont déjà mutualisés c'est
un facteur d'attraction aussi peut-être
ça va faire venir plus d'étudiants quant
à la tenue effective mans donc c'est bon
là je pense que les confusions je pense
que les étudiants que plutôt en licence
quoi qu'on a attendu gran master
effectivement il ya les deux chiens ou
s'ils sont dix pour cent des masters qui
sont mutualisés sur saclay or on voit
effectivement sur les mains sur les
sciences technologie qui est toujours un
peu un souci pas seulement chez nous on
te demande maintenant aux séparations
on a un afflux apportant de nouvelles
candidatures vous savez je présente sur
la master d'informatique quand on a un
master en avait je crois à peu près 50
300 de plus de candidats dont 50% de
plus de candidats grèce a fait beaucoup
comment ça se passe et pour les
étudiants qui ont justement sa tenue des
raisons va se mettre de plus en plus en
place qui va vraiment être en forme pour
des changements voit pas forcément parce
qu'il ya une occasion c'est à dire qu on
essaie d'avoir un programme pédagogique
commun ensuite effectivement les
étudiants peuvent se retrouver dans la
même salle où même amphithéâtre
ça dépend des disciplines on assume on
indication ou duplique si je suis en
pleine expression des formations c'est à
dire non à des master de droit qui ont
eu à la fois sur 50 à 28 en cours
également sursaut en partenariat avec
asus mais sur les sciences technologie
on pourra voir les formations
effectivement étude en ce moment même la
même salle le mans fit donc une partie
des coûts ronde est petite averse à l
autre partie alors c voire même à
critiquer ça c'est pas c'est pas c'est
pas forcément une innovation à ce que
les prochaines étapes vraiment entre
voile à l'université apprendre et parler
avec lesquels vous comptez mettre
plusieurs étapes passionnel pédagogique
dont on vient de démarrer dont il faut
pas non plus brûler les étapes si je
puis dire
donc l'état pour rattraper la logique
c'est de faire entrer les distances dans
le planète d'ici 4-5 ans pourra
heureusement 2020 ensuite un autre
aspect plus institutionnel c'est comment
évolue ce qu'on appelle aujourd'hui la
communauté d'université d'établissement
mais c'est le chantier étant vient de
commencer mais c'est pas très concret ce
cas vous donner ce sont ces bêtes voilà
ces dons
plusieurs années 2020 mais ce que à
terme on pourrait penser que je vais à
l'inversé de versailles saint quentin va
se fondre complètement dans celle de
paris saclay pour ça que oui c'est une
hypothèse qui on peut retenir qu'on peut
envisager il compte plusieurs visages la
même pu la communauté envisage la même
manière que l'université de paris sud où
l'université d'evry 6 à rentrer dans le
périmètre pourrait se disent ou pensent
pas qu'à long terme qui sera
relativement positifs se fondre dans la
cité par est sacrée restera à envisager
la position positionnement après année
pour les étudiants
je pense oui donc je pense quand même
que au delà la complexité de l'objet et
puisqu'on a des écoles des universités
des écoles qui relève de la défense
densément supérieur de l'agriculture de
l'industrie s'appelle pas comme ça mais
vous voyez on a quand même réussi à
avancer significativement
je crois qu'il ya pas d'autres
communautés des universités
établissements en france qui soit aussi
avancée que nous en termes de
mutualisation souvent mutualisent
d'écoles doctorales ce qu'ils ont fait
ça reste cohérent alors c'est par contre
au niveau master on a vraiment beaucoup
avancé en cohérence à camille entoure
les masters et c'est sûr oui c'était
l'occasion quand même de faire un petit
peu de rénovation pédagogique sur les
programmes de faire travailler des
équipes ensemble donc avec une ambition
dire une révolution une ambition
effectivement de faire mieux ensemble
était plus attractif notamment à
l'international bien et vous à pascal
ribot à vous avez des actrices de
l'estacade je le rappelle est une école
d'ingénieurs qui à mes élèves de post
bac à bac + 5
elle vient d'emménager à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines comment s'est
passée la rentrée pour vos 1200
étudiants
la rentrée s'est très bien passé là on a
fait rentrer les preuves des premières
au quatrième année bon les étudiants qui
avaient connu le site de levallois était
particulièrement content il est arrivé
dans des locaux tout neufs
c'est vrai que nos locaux de levallois
était relativement anciens et puis
beaucoup plus étroit donc pour eux c'est
l'occasion de d'imaginer une façon de
travailler qui est beaucoup plus
collaborative beaucoup plus d espace des
ateliers un travail avec nos chercheurs
aussi plus coopératif
donc ils sont
ils sont tous très très enthousiaste je
voulais cause de regarder parce que
justement nous sommes allés voir vos
études vous voir vous demandez comment
s'était passée la rentrée pour elle aura
bien un petit peu sur l'école regardez
c'est top c'est neuf c'est joli un
endroit sympa donc que demander de plus
une école qui est très apprécié par les
entreprises avec beaucoup de débauche et
à la sortie et j'ai choisi ces cas parce
que j'ai trop voulu être ingénieur dans
les transports
un licol il ya une super ambiance enfin
un écran sous entendant bien
ça change de l'ancien campus on a plus
de place c'est plus neuf
ça fait plaisir d'être dans un autre
cadre de vie et ce sera certainement
moins stressant qu'un levallois il ya
plusieurs écoles dans le domaine
aéronautique
moi je voulais une école qui était
directement après après le bac donc une
prépa intégrée alors j'ai choisi
l'estaca parce que depuis que je suis
tout jeune je suis passionné par les han
par le ferroviaire et des transports
guidés et c'est la seule école en europe
qui forment les étudiants à cette
filière parce qu'elle arrive - qui ont
tous nous rappeler voilà brièvement
pourquoi justement vous avez choisi ce
site de saint quentin en yvelines pour
installer l'école les stagiaires alors
comme vous l'avez entendu l'école est
spécialisé dans le secteur des
transports en forme des jeunes pour
l'industrie automobile industrie
aéronautique le spatial le ferroviaire
et ce grand territoire d'abord ce grand
territoire du plateau de saclay pour
nous était à celui qui était le le le
plus porteur en terme de d'innovation
dans ces domaines là et le territoire de
saint quentin en yvelines
c'est un territoire qui regroupe
beaucoup d'industriels qui sont des
industriels avec lequel on a l'habitude
de travailler qui embauchent nos
étudiants avec lequel nous avons des
partenariats sur des projets et
finalement c'était un petit peu
rejoindre notre famille que de
s'installer ici
et puis il y avait aussi ce partenariat
de longue date avec l'université de
versailles saint quentin en yvelines et
en particulier sur le sur le
projet c'était le projet qui est devenu
l'institut vd comme qui a joué aussi un
rôle important et d'un point de vue plus
se professionnalise entre guillemets
vous proposez à vos étudiants beaucoup
de stages est-ce que vous avez déjà déjà
noué des partenariats avec des acteurs
locaux des acteurs économiques locaux
on en avait déjà un certain nombre comme
je le disais ce choix ça a été aussi lié
à la présence de partenaires sur ce
territoire
on va les renforcer ses partenariats
on travaille par exemple en ce moment à
la mise en place d'un fab lab c'est à
dire d'un lieu où les étudiants vont
pouvoir aller jusqu'à la fabrication
avec les entreprises et c'est un projet
qu'on développe avec quelques acteurs
locaux voilà on n'a pas encore
complètement défini les deux trois
premiers projets sur lequel on allait
démarrer mais évidemment pour nous il
s'agit travailler avec les entreprises
qui sont sur place viser vraiment les
grosses entreprises pour que les
étudiants et des stages assurer sa non
pas que les autres pas que les autres
entreprises
nos étudiants vont à la fois travailler
dans des grosses entreprises dans des
pme il se passe des choses très très
intéressante dans les pme et jusque dans
les start up et donc nous on travaille
avec l'ensemble des entreprises c'est
vrai que les grosses font partie de nos
partenaires de très longue date mais on
développe à la fois les projets et les
stages avec des pme
j'en ai bavé servent aussi à
l'université vous développer des
partenariats avec les entreprises avec
les gros c'est une volonté d'aller plus
loin un président depuis la naissance un
petit peu l'université et comme les
universités qu'on appelle encore
nouvelles comme le jury cergy pontoise -
la vallée ont conduit à inventer un
modèle un petit peu de développement
différent des universités plus ancienne
et qui puisait ça c'était à une autre
façon de voir universités ont créé un
lien et toi étroit avec le directoire
notamment entreprises ont donc les deux
grands axes du partenaire de prise c'est
l'apprentissage puisque on a plus de
2000 heures apprentis une cité de 1460
dernière également de l'activité
contractuelle de recherche avec une
entreprise bon notamment dans le cas de
ski wauquiez pascal ribot vd comme donc
on a pas mal de bataille
un de recherche et donc de formation et
je crois que c'est parce que tout comme
pour une école d'ingénieur ou université
notre apport important c'est l'assertion
nos étudiants et la majorité des
étudiants la grande majorité ça serve
dans le monde de l'entreprise publique
ou privée c'est une minorité qui font la
recherche publique et de l'enseignement
aujourd'hui une dernière question
rapidement pour clôturer cet entretien
vous savez qu'il ya encore des
bacheliers qui n'ont pas encore
l'université il y en a près cette
mission sans france a représenté
seulement 1 % des étudiants post bac
ils ont parfois des difficultés à
trouver des failles qui n'ont pas encore
été attribués lors dernière choix
possibilité c'est le tien satan vous
avez comme moi j'ai pas de cas même à
sur le cac qui ceux qui se présentent
peut-être laissé par arriver jusqu'à moi
bon faut quand même bien il faut bien
voir que la situation
les obligations pour les recteurs de
s'occuper de l'assertion 18 ans mais
c'est pas forcément là où on sait ça
peut être dans les classes préparatoires
en bts
il faut voir aussi que nombre de ces cas
c'est pas nouveau a dit tous les ans il
ya des étudiants qui font pas forcément
les bons choix parce que s'il ya peu
compliqué dès fois pdg vue à le cas d'un
étudiant en fin d'année elle quitte la
machine qui a appris que les classes
préparatoires il a été pris nulle part
mais après ici voilà ou alors le
l'étudiante a le bateau wiki qui est un
buteur cinéma qui veut aller à parler de
faire de droit alors qu'il ya à créteil
il n'y pas plus à paris deux jours il se
retrouve juste d'être à l'estaca vous
récupérez des élèves savent ou qui
viennent justement à cause de ça t'est
ptit ont peur de la faculté de ses
premiers ça vous fait plus d'étudiants
et qui souhaitent s'inscrire
alors ce qu'on le choix de l'estac est
souvent chez nous d'ailleurs dans apb
c'est pour beaucoup d'étudiants un
premier choix vous avez vu que c'est des
jeunes qui sont passionnés pour la
plupart on a 80 % de premier choix dans
apb parmi les jeunes qui nous rejoignent
donc la question se pose est
généralement pas sur cet angle là de
leur part c'est à dire souvent ils font
ils regardent les écoles qui vont leur
permettre par exemple de travailler dans
le domaine aéronautique est donc dans
admission postbac
ils essayent de balayer l'ensemble des
formations qui leur permettra de
redonner ses parents auxquels vous êtes
confrontés les élèves a choisi ce dom en
amont bien merci à vous d'être venu sur
notre plateau et d'avoir répondu à nos
questions
nous continuerons justement avec un
sujet patrimoine c'était un week end
festif pour la ville de bois d'arcy avec
la fête de la saint gilles la deuxième
édition
des fêtes du sport et la remise des
trophées les artisans étaient de sortie
ce week-end la ville célébrée samedi
comme tous les ans son saint patron
autour d'un rassemblement convivial
williams elle et elodie moines derniers
préparatifs avant le début des
festivités de la saint gilles samedi
dernier la ville de bois d'arcy invité
tous les arcisien à célébrer leur saint
patron
ça permet de rentrer dans cette année
scolaire qui apporte toujours un petit
peu de stress et d'angoissé
ça permet également bien évidemment de
d'apporter de la joie la convivialité du
rassemblement rassemblement très
familial au programme de la soirée
distribution de lampions puis retraite
aux flambeaux
grande nouveauté de cette année
l'événement se déroulait sur le canal de
la croix bonus on a un site magnifique
qui n'avait jamais été exploitée
auparavant et qu'on va essayer
aujourd'hui de mettre en valeur de
valoriser et ça nous permet également de
relier ce quartier tout neuf et moderne
delattre abonnés à la ville de val d'or
en plus des animations qui vont ponctuer
cette semaine la fête de la saint gilles
est aussi un moyen pour les habitants de
se rencontrer dans une ambiance festive
oui bien sûr ça nous permet de voir
des habitants d'un quartier on se
retrouve là comme avec les
les anciens c'est sympa c'est convivial
pour rencontrer voisins les personnes de
la ville des élus aussi c'est vraiment
sympa c'est pour fêter la rentrée se
doit les enfants
la retraite après lumière et qui volent
d'artifice le feu d'artifice clou du
spectacle si elle est depuis le canal de
la croix bonnet était suivi d'un bal
populaire la fête de la saint gilles a
tout de même rassemblé plus de 3000
personnes secondes et c'est aussi la
rentrée culturelle à saint quentin en
yvelines pour en parler avec nous ce
soir sephora namani notre journaliste
culture mont foire sephora on ressort
fleuret alors nous avons parlé théâtre
ce soir exactement florennes alors pour
cette chronique culture nous allons
parler de la rentrée au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines scène
nationale installée à montigny le
bretonneux le directeur lunel masse et à
signe sa première programmation rappelle
qu'il a été nommé en octobre dernier sur
recommandation de la rue de valois alors
pour cette programmation deux mots
d'ordre diversité et pluridisciplinarité
les détails c'est lionel messi était
lui-même qui ne les donne c'est de
rentrer c'est une année une année de
transition
cette année cette saison 2015 2016
les transitions avec on va dire une
saison qui est extrêmement ouverte est
ouverte à toutes les disciplines ouverte
à toutes les écritures de la scène et
puis une saison je regardais la plaque
est juste ou ce matin et je regardais
les huit premiers spectacles qui se
trouve sur les 8 premiers spectacles ya
cinq équipes étrangères lorsque on parle
d'ouverture on parle aussi l'ouverture
de ce lieu d'ouverture du territoire en
acadie qui de france est bien entendu
mais également des équipes qui viennent
du japon qui viennent d'italie qui
viennent de belgique quotidienne de
corée donc ça c'est quelque chose
d'assez d' assez réjouissant ce qui nous
faut aujourd'hui c'est continuer à avoir
cette ouverture sur le monde éviter de
se renfermer et de s'enfermer sur soi
même alors quelques spectacles pour
illustrer cette volonté d'ouverture en
danse je danse parce que je me méfie des
mots de kaori ito chorégraphe japonaise
il s'agit d'un univers personnel déployé
avec humour force et sensualité ce sera
les 14 et 15 octobre en théâtre notre
peur de n'être avec le talentueux
metteur en scène fabrice murgia le 3
novembre
il s'agit d'une pièce autour de la
solitude de l'homme moderne
à l'ère du virtuel et puis plus proche
de nous le 13 octobre natacha atlas
divo riant à les célèbres crooneuse pour
un mélange de jazz et de musiques du
monde
natacha atlas pour ceux qui ne se
souviennent pas c'est ça
ouais
kima
que je tombe je
m
me gillot
le policier
donc natacha atlas et le 13 octobre au
théâtre national de saint-quentin pour
terminer sur cette programmation peut
être une dernière est cette fois alors
le 25 septembre c'est le spectacle qui
va lancer la saison et c'est également
le coup de coeur du directeur du théâtre
national big sonne c'est signé chez sal
un compositeur qui a l'art d'harmoniser
différents univers et qui cette fois ci
fait résonner la musique antillaise on
en écoute un extrait
donc riche et diversifiée lionel masse
et à directeur du théâtre at il atteint
son objectif de s'ouvrir à un large
public pour tenter de le vérifier
nous sommes allés le demander aux
premiers concernés les spectateurs micro
trottoir c'est toujours bon à prendre
non mais bon je pense que gardent un peu
de classique se serait pas non plus trop
mal parce que pour la culture c'est
toujours bon signe avant et j'aimerais
aussi voir quelque chose des espagnols
flamenco par exemple la danse aussi
balle est classique et moderne
valen moderne aussi bien en a pour tous
les goûts donc honnêtement ce point me
donnait envie tiens pourquoi pas moi qui
n'ai pratiquement jamais de découvrir de
nouveaux trucs être accessible dans la
programmation c'est bien mais il dans
les prix c'est mieux me direz-vous
florane est justement
sachez qu'il existe des formules
d'abonnement entre 28 et 128 euros pour
découvrir les différents arts du
spectacle et élargir ses horizons
si on est sur une bonne variété sur une
telle diversité de spectacles tout en
conservant pour chacun des spectacles
une véritable exigence c'est aussi que
l'on a envie que les public puisse
découvrir toutes les disciplines
puissent découvrir des artistes des
artistes confirmés
alors ils s'en sont pas des découvertes
mais aussi de jeunes artistes donc les
abonnements font fait de sorte que voilà
en un site au maximum les publics les
spectateurs et les spectateurs
potentiels à venir découvrir tout un
panel d'artistes et l'abonnement il sert
essentiellement à ça et si vous voulez
réserver
rendez vous sur le site internet du
théâtre l'adresse s'affiche à l'écran
juste le temps de vous dire que pour
retrouver toute l'actualité culturelle
et donc la programmation des salles sur
saint quentin en yvelines et ses
alentours
vous pouvez vous rendre sur kiosque
point est-ce qu y point fr et quant à
coeur ce que le magazine fera son retour
dès ce mercredi sur tv fil 78
18h30 19h30 et 23h avec vous ces fora au
programme alors nous parlerons bien sûr
du tricentenaire de la mort de louis xiv
du 50e anniversaire de la disparition de
l'architecte le corbusier et de son
influence sur saint quentin et du
festival orphée qui démarrera le
week-end prochain à versailles eh bien
merci à sephora nous découvrirons tout
cela mercredi pour finir cette édition
un mot de sport vous avez peut-être
regarder le match
rugby de ce samedi france ecosse dernier
match de préparation avant la coupe du
monde qui se déroule en angleterre et
commença dès vendredi prochain alors la
france future championne du monde
est ce que vous y croyez c'est ce que
nous vous avons demandé regarder est-ce
que vous pensez que la france peut être
championne du monde de rugby
non je pense pas parce qu'il ya des
nations qui me paraissent plus mieux
préparés et peut-être plus forte
je crois qu'il ya les fortes équipes du
côté de l'écossé de l'irlande peut être
pas gagné ça peut être compliqué mais
faire un petit résultat pourquoi pas
j'espère toujours et oui parce qu'ils
peuvent avoir l'équipe qu'il faut mais
fournier qui secoue un peu plus tant que
ça prendrait il sera à la tête de
l'équipe de france je crois pas j'ai un
petit peu de mal à l'imaginer je dois
bien l'avouer donc au vu des derniers
résultats
ça me paraît pas forcément évident
sûrement là ses chances oui pas de
problème
moi j'y connais vraiment rien au rugby
j'ai désolé là c'est pas le bon et c'est
la fin de cette édition tout de suite ne
manquez pas le retour du 7-8 sport
présentée par michael et demi d'euros il
sera aussi question de rugby pour ma
part je vous retrouve demain à 18 heures
pour le direct je vous souhaite une
excellente vrai